justice à présent rappelez-vous en 2019
le sort de l'ours micha avait ému la
france entière l'ursidé détenu à
chauvigny du perche par le couple
poliakov vivait dans des conditions
indignes
l' affaire avait été médiatisée par le
biais d'une vidéo en caméra cachée
aujourd'hui le tribunal administratif
d'orléans devait se prononcer sur les
manquements de l'état mais également
l'interdiction pour le couple
d'accueillir d'autres animaux
explications hélène chapelet faut-il
laisser les polyakov ses dresseurs
installé dans le loir-et-cher détenir
des animaux sauvages
c'était l'une des questions posées
aujourd'hui au tribunal administratif
d'orléans par l'association animalistes
one voice ses habitants de chauvigny du
perche se sont fait connaître après la
divulgation d'une vidéo montrant les
conditions de vie indignes de leurs
trois ours
l'un d'entre eux mischa est finalement
décédé en novembre 2019
malgré les soins qui lui ont été
prodigués dans un refuge
l'objectif de cette audience pour one
voice était donc notamment d'obtenir le
retrait des deux certificats de capacité
d'espèces non domestiques détenu par le
couple ont demandé deux choses à ce que
les animaux qui sont encore chez
monsieur madame polyakov soient retirés
ainsi que toutes les autorisations
administratives qui leur permettent
justement de détenir ces animaux l'enjeu
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on sorte les
animaux qui sont toujours détenus cela
dira ya plusieurs perroquet en tout
traces perroquets et le petit macaque
qui est toujours détenu chez les poyas
qu'offre la décision du tribunal
d'orléans a été mise en délibéré au 29
avril
les polyakov n'ont pas fini avec la
justice puisque le couple est poursuivi
au pénal pour actes de cruauté mauvais
traitements y sévissent grave
leur procès aura lieu le 12 mai prochain
devant le tribunal de blois